I see for me you're not going but I
charge you for this one
okay that's no problem yeah
Bronk when Kass was arriving restaurant
the very first time and they make a
mistake on their order yeah we have to
be prepared to change you want the
customers to come back right yeah what
will happens next
this one ice take away maybe you can
have it tomorrow
ah that's really kind thank you yes cuz
I hardly touched it
I'm very good thank you
no that's incredibly quick how did you
do that well you have to do it with him
at the same time so I just had to speed
the process thank you thank you thank
you so much this is absolutely delicious
I have been to Marrakech some of the
best food I've ever had and this takes
me right back so he pulled it back in a
very charming way see and look at the
difference in what happened when we
changed that dish amazing I love this
place Chris is amazing so charming your
customers are in love with you and your
food okay
and if you want to charge them ring me
up and I'll pay for the [ __ ] dish
okay
I've got a butch in I trust my team I
believe in my team and that did happen
it won't happen again and that's it
now is let's see what's coming ahead
assume oh I found my test really tough
but honestly I do admire their fighting
spirit now it's time for the final
challenge as both teams cross London to
come and cook in my flagship restaurant
and this is a very last chance they've
got to shine
the test is to create one mind-blowing
dish worthy of my michelin-starred
restaurant I wanted to really push
themselves and cook like they've never
done before only one restaurant to go
through semi-finals this is what dreams
are made of a farmer's boy I mean I've
lived as a butcher so this is this is
not to met him proud as well I want to
win I really want to win
being in Ramsay's restaurant it's an
honor and I'm very very happy I think
I'm not gonna disappoint him
tonight it is very very important day
welcome welcome good to see right during
this competition because both your
restaurants are unique the excitement
behind the North African cuisine and
what it can deliver in textures flavors
spice is mind-blowing this is the dish
of your life right because this is was
going to cal upon one of you into the
semi-final make sure it's you good luck
I've asked them to come up with one
exquisite dish featuring lab a star
ingredient of North African cuisine
one side with the zoo you've got
traditional and the other side with Momo
you've got this new wave a light style
of North African cuisine and completely
opposite end of the spectrum to help me
choose who's best
both teams creations will be served a
highly distinguished guests including
LCA Wu Zhu director of the Royal African
society Lobby Remi key head of culture
and press at the Moroccan Embassy and
distinguished Moroccan chef and
restauranteur Joseph Burrell LT the
front of house teams from both
restaurants are also dining here today
David is an excellent chef I know
everything is going to be delicious
it's like a holiday cooking for 20 I'm
usually cooking for 200 so should
technically be a walk in the park it's
an enormous challenge I think he will
cope very well ok